okay so we have our next 3x3 up and I
can already tell who this is wait really
I I I'm I'm pretty confident I'm pretty
damn confident we got Hunter Hunter 2011
I assume yuio Dragon Ball Z code gas
attack on J kaen Death Note villain Saga
what's that last one code gas oh it's C
why did they pick that pict no code gas
is up there so what's that one that is
what is that what's the last one that is
Code G no it's not that looks like the
Luan that looks like the zero mask I
don't know what that is oh Casher
sins
Casher oh my God I know that what's cash
huh the [__] is Cash ear cashen sins is
the beta
Cod I would I wouldn't go that far um is
this Charlie's I'm pretty confident it's
Charlie got this is the
most male anime fan generic list ever
okay yeah that makes
sense that makes say not a single
romance or or Slice of Life to be seen
not a single Sports Anime everything is
action manly stuff
[__] men men boys boys boys this is
the boys Charlie yeah it's got to be
what's the bottom right one oh it is
cash and wow he watched cash and sins
what the [__] is cash and sins I don't
even know what this is it did it come
out before or after I can't remember
it's before right it is an action anime
that's all I really know about it I I
didn't watch it I didn't actually watch
it I haven't watched it in years
um I think it might be kind of like it's
a me pretty 7.5 on Ma that is literally
the most seven like that means it's like
a five out of 10 but one thing that I I
am guessing why Charlie put this on is
that it just has a very badass art style
and a very badass visual kind of like
identity is true uh which you know I
know Charlie would be a big fan of does
Charlie have a reason for putting cash
and SS in
no all right well I mean okay let's
let's go let's go through this even
though this screams this already screams
yes makes sense because he said on trash
taste that that's his favorite anime of
all time it's valid which is valid I
could see why someone would be their
favorite I know you went through a phase
of collecting Yu-Gi-Oh cards as well so
Yu-Gi-Oh is just great I just love the
memes I love the I don't know the Yu-Gi
fandom seems like they have a good time
it's so quotable as well it's such a
great show you're the dub is great
you're what is so you're a third rate
jewelist no you're a fourth rate
jewelist with a third rate deck or
something see the problem with the dub
is that I don't know like I literally
can't tell which scenes are from the
original dub and which scenes are from
Yu-Gi-Oh bridge I think I think I one I
quot is from the bridge actually so I
think the No it should have been me I
think that's from the I think that's
from the that's from no no It Should
Have Been Me Not him that's from the
original I don't [__] know anymore
but I keep quoting like well thege my
deck has no pathetic cards Yugi which I
think is from Yu-Gi-Oh or bridge if I
and then obviously the [__] pot of
greed meme is from the the the [__]
bridged that's which one pot of greed
they're like what does pot of greed do
and like no one ever no one knows no one
knows what pot of greed does oh know I I
think that just became a meme because
every time part of greed came on part of
greed came on they would always explain
the power even though it was the most
simple card you could possibly pull from
the deck and wasn't it like it was like
that you explain how pot of greed works
by using pot of greed or something yeah
yeah and then I and then I summon
another pot of greed I I unfortunately
have no idea which memes yeah like you
said come from the bridge come from the
actual dub I have have you noticed pot
of greed is basically just every ugly
bastard [__] design you've seen from
H yeah it is kind of confusing and kind
of concerning yeah look look at this
[__] it's my favorite [__] card bro
can we agree that the it's that
smile you're s and got turned on and
thought hold on now wait a minute wait a
minute oh I have an actual pot of greed
that's actually that's really really
sick I I I think the Dual disc is
probably the right the hardest piece of
equipment in all of all time it goes so
hard the what the Dual disc oh the
[__] coolest piece of anime
merchandise kid every kid so iconic
having one I I had one as a kid you did
I could I couldn't get my parents to buy
me one I wanted one of these so bad when
I was a kid holy Fu it was so sick but I
remember it was so annoying having to
keep your arm like up all the time while
you're playing but it it felt so [__]
badass that you didn't even mind I what
a cool piece of equipment that is the
coolest card game kind of like piece of
equipment that has ever come out that's
crazy that someone's making a video
being like I got a real dual death like
it's some kind of ancient artifact
whereas I just had when as a kid and I'm
like [__] what I loved was the little
section uh above where you yeah where
you could like put your actual deck
inside of it and you can pull it out
yeah there's the graveyards at the
bottom your life points were there it
was such a cool such a [__] cool
piece of [__] genius God I wish that
yu- came out when nerd culture was a bit
more um accepted because yeah Georges
unironically one of the coolest things
ever I would love to see what a high
like high spec
build an actual an actual High spec
custom build of a jewel disc would look
like cuz obviously this looks like you
know can we buy want to play Yu-Gi-Oh
with it sure I really want to I've never
played yuoh before I oh you want I've
never played y before I I've played
Yu-Gi-Oh a few times in my in my life
but I've recently played the forbidden
Memories PS1 game oh yeah yeah uh which
came out before the official rules of
Yu-Gi-Oh were established and uh I
played it cuz there's a this they it's
like the craziest speedrun of all time
oh yeah yeah because the game is [__]
it's RNG yeah they made the game
impossible it's so [__] hard um isn't
like the the 100% record is like 70
something hours or something yeah
because you have to get like 700 cards
and some of the cards actually a lot of
the cards have 0.1 drop rates so you
have to just grind and it's like K
Konami was just hated kids well that was
a fun game and may it made me really
want to play more Yu-Gi-Oh cuz I thought
I love Yu-Gi-Oh it's so cool monster
designs are just so cool so cool yeah I
mean of course Attack on Titan is on
there as well uh I saw his video where
he did very much enjoy the ending uh on
the same I I mean I think Charlie puts
it on the same level as code gas now
just as a whole damn as his like
favorite anime uh DBZ he obviously grew
up with I assume yes same with like uh
death note I would assume Vinland Saga
yeah I mean who [__] doesn't like
like Hunter Hunter Vinland Saga like who
doesn't like it uh jutu kaon I'm not
surprised not surprised I think it's if
you're watching jutu kaon right now well
I guess when this is when this is out
it's finished airing but there's two
week two episodes left before it's so
hard not to think that it's like [__]
amazing I should all like it's the only
anime I really want to keep watching
every week it's like the latest Shia Arc
has just been that modern shown in Arc
classic in my opinion it's insane people
are going to be talking about this Arc
for generations to come so that doesn't
surprise me but yeah it's this is this
is it this is the boys only Club you
know this is sometimes might I don't
know if your guys's Twitter feed has
been just taken over by Shonen fans
recently I think it's because J Tyson
thankfully not is it not no every day I
log onto my Twitter and someone is
making a certain thread of like oh here
are some manga panels that go hard oh
I've seen those yeah yeah manga panels
that go hard and [__] like that and it's
the same [__] 10 shows it's it's like
they might throwing D every now it was
just like out of nowhere incest scene in
J Jutsu kaison recently and that kind of
blew up and I I remember when I watched
it I was like
huh they kept that in they kept that in
yeah there was just a random incest part
that kind of came out of nowhere it was
really weird it literally came out of
nowhere God safe yeah and and and it it
was really funny watching Twitter react
because they were like it was like a
bunch of like all the cuz there was this
one tweet that blew up that was like
ain't no way they put this in the anime
and it was just showing off in not but
but even more concerning incest with
like a really older sister and a very
young brother oh switching they're
actually and they're actually blood
related they're blood related it's none
of this like step sibling [__] they
fully committing and it was just out of
nowhere in the middle of like the most
hype [__] ever and they were like incest
you like [__] what Jesus Christ and
then all the replies were like Vegeta
with like bloodshot eyes like screaming
being like why is she so bad
though and it's like what is wrong with
Twitter it was like literally like
Vegeta coughing up blood being like I
don't care though I
word it's like what is wrong with
Twitter like what have we what have we
done what have we done to these people
it's it's so amazing how like DBZ is
just one of those shows where every non
DBZ anime fan just loves to clown on
that Community but [__] me they make
they still make some of the best goddamn
memes and reaction images hon like the
modern show in I'm like maybe maybe we
were too maybe we were too harsh on DBZ
fans well I think it's cuz Goku and
Vegeta have such Rec like they're so
recognizable which lends to their meme
ability in the same way that like Mario
and Sonic are often Meed because they're
so wiely recognized yeah totally I'm
just I'm just liking the fact that there
are more anime screenshots that are just
becoming widespread memes now like I the
one I've seen recently that's been
spread around is the one where like
gun's about to go for the attack and K
just like got his hand on the shoulder
which is like normally used when
someone's like overshooting a tweet or
someone's like someone's like saying
something that might have been going a
little bit too far and someone just
replies that and I'm like that's so
[__]
good oh my God yeah um I mean there's
not much else to say about this one good
taste Charlie I mean Charlie this is
just good taste we know this is good
taste and like your your bro comes to
you
is like hey I want to get into anime
welcome to the starter pack yeah